[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
ouais
[Musique]
non
ah ah
là pour savoir ça va bien merci
classement sur la liste noire
quelque chose oui ilham où les coins du
champagne non non je n'aime pas le
champagne
porto por tout rouge forte hausse et du
porto parler du porto évidemment du
champagne dans une coupe de champagne au
porto alors de partir en vacances un peu
non je peux partir en vacances hier neuf
ans que je pète est en vacances
la santé très bonne j'aurai besoin de
dijon vous ayez pris un moment devant de
la course donc nous en avait pris pour
fou de votre vie oui on peut raisonner
comme vous il est vrai aussi
j'espère qu à l époque où une personne
savez vous étiez vous étiez leur
avant-bras et des pagnes et je lui
souhaite
pourquoi ce qu'a gagné non oui bon il ya
d'autres arbres gré à gré sont en dehors
des familles les bananiers les manguiers
c'est des pistes que vous donnez le nom
dont le
les arbres des pagodes je dirais un jour
je dois vous le demande est vrai que
j'ai interviewé steve en effet jamais pu
savoir me dit vous direz un jour la
vérité là dessus peut-être oui dans
mémoires non les mémoires ça fait un peu
ce à la veille de la motion voulez
manger quoi jacques un je ne sais pas
quand je le vois très piquant merci
buvez du vin jacques ripoll entier mais
tu vin rouge et vin rouge magouilles
bourgueil un truc comme ça bouge à
dubout regagner la rive sud et steeple
les cent jours de chirac pour des gains
de jugement dessus je pense que ce sera
mon chapeau ces cours de ski libre je
pense d'autre part sur certaines choses
sur les essais qui explique en grande
partie désarroi de l'opi dans un
désarroi provisoire d'opinion je pense
que là il ya beaucoup de démagogie
est ce que la france doit être une
puissance nucléaire
c'est la cité la décision du général de
gaulle je pense qu'elle est juste c'est
une des conditions de l'indépendance de
la france
il l'a mal expliquent les experts ni par
expliquent des experts disent il faut
des essais pour maintenir la crédibilité
de cet art je ne suis pas un expert mais
s'ils ne disent pourquoi pas et comme je
vois critiques et cela au nom des
populations du pacifique des australiens
je me dit monsieur vous avez un sacré
culot sillage le site parfait accompli
commis dans le monde c'est celui des
tasmanienne way le dernier mâle comme
vous dites messieurs les australiens le
dernier mâle est mort en 1860
et la dernière femelle en 1876 et cette
dernière femelle vous l'avez empaillés
il voulait des exposés au musée de
hobart en temps quand vous ai alors dit
horaires et aujourd'hui vous allez nous
dire que vous respectez les populations
du pacifique des pots de fleurs
quand je vois cette pilote américaine
devrait vous prendre que nous porte
parole du gouvernement
c'est pas beau cas c'est aussi bien que
l'uranium de chirac quand il dit que
l'australie vendu radio je vois cette
femme d'impôt là je ne sais trop quoi
qui pilote l'hélicoptère de greenpeace
et qui se définit comme un vétéran du
vietnam afrique
elle dit qu'elle admire il l aime
beaucoup les dauphins oui la vie est là
du napalm et pas mal de gerty est calé
contre le nucléaire
je me dis alors on n'a pas trop là de
conscience une dédiée tabia ne sont pas
des bannis faire marin ip le napalm avec
lequel on les brûlait n'était pas
nucléaire bon mais je dis à quel titre
donne un droit d'humanité à picot
ça me plaît
très bon
ça me fait rire doit manger avec des
baguettes pardon ça me fait rire de
ranger ta gueule puisque ces voitures
qui étaient là mais non j'ai trop
tourner des scènes non
j'ai invité de plusieurs années vous
allez y aller je lis harrison
je peux vous en prendre aux très bonnes
je suis extrêmement gourmand vous vous
parlez souvent merci quand on voit où
bat quand vous avez souvent des mots je
dis pas dur mais des mots un peu
ironique merci ou sara leal à l'égard de
l'humanitarisme je vous dirais que sur
les doigts de l'eau mise je croirais
monsieur kouchner
si l'année d'abord eu samedi à paris
pour regarder les ghanéennes qui vendent
leur plupart semblent essayer d'y mettre
fin non pas en les expulsant mais en
trouvant une solution humanitaire
une neige ça il le fera pas je ne vois
pas comment quand on connaît la rue
saint-denis et les ghanéennes de la rue
saint denis
on peut tout d'un coup de lever le doigt
et dire le droit ou chinois au
singapourien et aux algériens la
colonisation qui étaient inexactes à
dire que n'oublions pas pathogène
isation a été faite par jules ferrer qui
disait très franchement il fallait
conquérir des marchés
ouais et les kouchner
bigot de l'époque disait que ce n'est
pas vrai dire les droits de l'homme
qu'on battrait pavillon noir
au vietnam les rois esclavagistes en
afrique
à l'époque on dit c'est l'évangile
un bon point maintenant ce qu'elle
droits de l'homme - mais c'est toujours
la volonté d'ingérence
on essaie de donner des leçons aux
sommes aujourd'hui semaine avec le
succès que l'on sait pourquoi ne pas pas
dans les pays du golfe venues aider les
seconds respect de l'homme - à tous les
gens ces régions donc ce droit
d'ingérence humanitaire c'est ce droit
de l'hommisme universelle sur les masses
de l'impérialisme et d'une agression au
moins culturelle qui dit ça aujourd'hui
quel courage de dire ça aujourd'hui quel
courage de s'élever contre cette pensée
unique et contre ses bras mais d'entrée
parce qu'en même temps c'est en raison
de son confort mais ce qu'on peut
acquérir certaines prébendes samedi
sécurité il est évident que si j'avais
été l'avocat de quelques institutions
à l'époque je n'aurais pas pu défendre
barbie hors jeu on a beau être été
maladroit
si vous aviez été l'avocat du ap nous
saluons me dit non ouais mais je crois
que lorsqu'on a envie d'être indépendant
je ne parle pas des gens issus de
classes défavorisées mais quand on
obtient deux possibilités on a la
possibilité de ne pas courber le jeu de
se plier dans le pouvoir quel qu'il soit
et quelque chose et vous pourrez sur et
disons ce qu'on a fait le vulgairement
la matériel c'est à dire pourquoi vivre
normalement oui vous êtes quand même
amené à travailler pour des gens comme
mon goût des gens comme ça non oubliez
pas de prix génie politique
je ne dit pas qu'il n'y a pas de fausses
factures sans doute est il pas plus
qu'en france ça c'est clair
c'est à dire et le maître et de france
plus le professeur mais alors quand je
vois des socialistes et les socialistes
à l'époque au milieu d'accusations et
dirigeants et ya bien faire il mettait
en cause des dirigeants des cas à
l'époque où ils commençaient à organiser
leur graphique c'est la fille entretenu
qui traite de [ __ ] la fille qui fait
le trottoir
vous avez quand même lucides pragmatique
eux voire cynique
moi je sais ce que je pense je me
permets de lavrion sai cateau cochon le
cd petit truc rond et chaud qui ont
mairie côté auxerre est très sensuelle
oui d'accord coco chauds tels que ceux
en même temps oui ce serait quoi votre
monde idéal vous avez vous préféré pas y
penser
non je pensais pas de mon idéal et je
l'écris au communisme je crois toujours
dans certaines choses les communes dans
certaines choses l'analyse critique du
communisme et bonne là où ça commence à
devenir dangereuse mais quand l'art
construit quoi c'est dans sa
reconstruction de la théologie voilà ces
niches qui le vivent c'est pas le but
qui sanctifie la lutte c'est la lutte
qui sanctifie de plus si on s'est bien
battu qu'on n'a pas comme une saloperie
je ne vois pas non plus éviter d'être
heureux vous admire et qui je vois qu'on
parle beaucoup du chase
oui ça revient j'ai rencontré le che
mais je n'aurais pas l'outrecuidance de
diège aider son ami et je les rencontre
d'autres l'ont fait à votre place je
vais j'ai rencontré sa première femme
péruvien ville d'agadez et est membre du
comité de rédaction de révolution le
journal dont j'étais le directeur
il a gagné plus souvent à paris avec
l'accord du che lui même de les
rencontrer
voilà un homme certainement que non je
regrette l'absence
parmi les contrats pourraient donner lui
sont tous morts la seule visite m oui
mais vivant ça sera un discret jeu si je
suit évidence aller compromettrait le
sol je veux dire qu'elle n'a pas non
plus des tonnes dont s'était compromis
très peu fatigant non mais je vous en
prie je préfère les pétards mme l'avant
saison heureux simple pourquoi ça tombe
sous le coup de la loi
ouais comme l'avortement et quelques
années nous donc c'est pas grave
ne pas besoin pensez quoi plutôt du bien
ouais fais pas partie des gens qui
attendent que le pape soit pour
l'avortement la sodomie sur tout le
monde et moi est très étonné que le
peuple soit chap
moi j'aime bien que le père sort soit
personne si oui est-ce que le gaz est
déjà mais que chinoise aux chinois je
pense que l'allemand soit l'alberta oui
même le bruit que le français soit le
français mais je ne veux pas la
nécessité que le que tout le monde soit
interchangeables dias et je vois pas
pourquoi le pape devrait résonner comme
d'anciens amis n'ont pas la même culture
on parlera mois s'ils n'ont pas la même
tradition mais adrian comme mon nom et
je ne veux pas pourquoi on exigerait de
lui qu'il connaisse tout le répertoire
des chansons de patrick bruel contre qui
je n'ai rien d'ailleurs ne fassions pas
de coco le pape devrait chanter les
chansons pour y représenter monsieur le
dos
oui c'est bien parce que vous savez
appuyer là où ça fait du bien là où ça
fait mal pour donner dans son confort
national gagne trois villes vous en
pensez quoi vous pensez que la
démocratie a été respectée
je ne vois pas comment on peut reprocher
si on dit des mots grâce à des gens de
gagner des voix aux élections
donc c'est la limite du sillage seule
question qu'on doit se poser c'est moi
qui suis contre
qu'est-ce que j'ai dû faire comme
conneries qu'aucune vannes pour qu'ils
aillent bon mais plutôt de dire je suis
un con une onde il est un [ __ ] je
pense que ce raisonnement je ne critique
pas sur le plan moral je ne critique sur
le plan tout à fait de l'efficacité que
je vais dire oui tant qu'on va dire de
l'équipe de football adverse qui ne
gagne pas ce qu'ils sont des [ __ ]
peut se demander pourquoi on perd je ne
crois pas qu'on prépare le vrai des gens
d'arriver au championnat du monde
moi je pense que
les soldats sont plus au coin des rues y
sont dans les têtes des gens maintenant
c'est à dire que la colonisation est
devenu mental c'est à dire que c'est
plus facile de se battre contre un
allemand
habillés en vert de gris sur qui on peut
tirer de sa fenêtre se battre contre
quelqu'un qui vous dit que bernard
kouchner est un sens oui je suis de lui
répondre mais qui vous dit bernard
kouchner est un saint rien alors que
l'allemagne avait le frisé qui au coin
de la rue pourrait toujours lui tiré à
vider votre chargeur dans le vent oui si
vous êtes cours à l'est après quand il
était en train d'agoniser d'essayer de
l'aider
tandis que kouchner
[Rires]
non je dis ça parce qu'il n'a pas besoin
d aide
il en dispose
vous gardez quoi je fais quand même
temps qu'il ya des des soldats qui
gardent l'ambassade d'israël pour ça
fait des amis des personnes qu'elle doit
placer dans la rue par itway les
voitures peuvent pas passer seulement
ceux qui sont autorisés à rentrer
d'autres kotick
vous allez où vous allez au jockey club
sait où est alors c'est quoi une soirée
schtroumpfs 1
c'est une soirée quoi c ou jockey club
ce débit en quoi la à un troubadour
vous chanter des chansons du moyen-âge
c'est genre quoi jean christophe
dechavanne a reconnu quand même vous
connaissez pas mais non c'est
l'ambassade d'israël là c'est pas de
joker
le juge chanter quoi sérieux non chant
composé par un compositeur conconne vrai
nom keith et des chants pour détrousser
moderne
ouais garder le luth et planck est là
pourquoi on n'a pas le droit de filmer
l'ambassade d'israël bon d'accord il en
saura comme ça mais le jockey club mais
si delarue quoi
27 rue de la rue rabelais ses talents
et donc vous êtes tous les quatre comme
ça vous chante et voilà c'est bien vous
avez pas la télé vous voudrez bien de la
chance on me salue sa bonne soirée les
troubadours
à bientôt
attention
ce soir
m
il
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
m
[Musique]
déjà bonsoir fou car à chaque fois c'est
un truc qui était leur beaucoup c'est
quand on me dit je m'en rappelle charles
charles de galles où charles de gaulle
où bird en toi un container en tant que
royalistes compter à peu devenu pianiste
bristol tapis de bain pianiste au
bristol pour arrondir mes fins de mois
et ma chambre
moyennant une heure de piano parce que
je prends mon nom venant là je fais des
dollars en jouant du caramel dur niveau
et j'en vois au ciel ceux qui sont pas
trop saouls qui meurent ans leur vie 36
en disant je quitte et igp et plus
et je leur serai
pour gagner ma vie ils me font merci
continuent leur bruit
où vient normandeau pour taper sur le
don ou baver sur les noirs du piano bar
où je joue chaque besoin
[Musique]
pas nous
un petit peu de tout
je suis un voyou
quand ils prennent la portent bien trop
vite pote tente linate
que je peux plus jouer
franck strode j'me payant glousse elle
la fing eu le double du monde joe tk pas
bien
on
[Musique]
on l'est à la capitale du jazz 60
jamais
j'ai mon qu'un d'un an de grosses bagues
en ont
un boum était au rwanda comme endroit
les gens rient encore encore je suis au
besoin sous on me lancent des bravos
j'ai appris par l amf année sacré
bombay et sam fadi mais ça me fatigue
saipem
[Musique]
ça finit déjà comme ça et l échange tu
sais jouer montréal
tu sais pas de jouer des postes le piano
comme ça ça c'est bon c'est bon tu peux
jouer sur demi-terrain bien se jouer en
full of a woman soit loi
[Musique]
infos gabon au fond
rex linn story
alors là ce texto me moby force en moi
mais mon programme
[Musique]
laboureur de bullet enfin de toujours
à toi dans les cinq absents - 15h un peu
de buts que je vais jouer parce que la
boue rire de bougue et enfumé l'as
monaco va s'appeler même à monsieur
hockey quand je saurai le pianiste au
bristol a voulu d'abord guy labory deux
bogeys raconte mon histoire d'abord deux
bogeys aux films plus nombreux explique
pourquoi laboureur de folie parce que
c'était parce que j'avais des charrettes
qui des labours c'est parce que les
bogeys libos guide parce qu'à l'époque
avant y'avait pas de ressort dans l'est
dans les rues des charrettes à chevaux
puis les gens dans des conteneurs
montréal
il mettait un espèce de foin pour
amortir les chocs et puis quand on
fumait du mauvais potes à l'époque ça
sent monter un peu la brûlure de boguey
je me souviens pas oui parce que je me
suis fait à la fois que j'étais
interviewé tu me raconter l'histoire
d'amour de boogie et puis tu me disais
un jour on était à los angeles avec des
copains et on avait été en avait pris un
acide tellement fort que l'autobus trêve
entrée dans la maison l'aurait même pas
ça serait même pas peur c'est comme ça
là porto avait sérieusement s'était
calmée et longtemps wiiware j'ai des
cheveux qui souhaitent y boit de la
bière
oui je plains d'halabja ça me fatigue un
peu embêté à bière un peu beaucoup
ouais ça marche bien aujourd'hui tu
gagnes plus de blé en faisant de la
bière on vend des disques
aujourd'hui j'ai vendu 80
une bouteille de bière quatre disques
celle là doit achever j'ai moi un truc
ce gentil est ce que je pourrais jouer
ensemble chez bang c'est dur de faire
montréal sur un cadeau pourri mais tient
au fait moi je passe je vous de l'amour
mon gars moi je t'ai fait chanter avec
louise ce que je fais chantier me
souviens je vais chanter mais là c'est
parce que l'union des musiciens
m'interdit moi de jouer puisque deux
minutes
oui je joue à maigrir minutes et vu
qu'il ne payera pas de droit d'auteur de
toute façon je veux chanter une chanson
de claude léveillée si tu vas manger je
dois plus facilement appelé là ça
commence comme ça
non
[Musique]
e
je me fous du monde entier car en fait
dès le rappeur les amours de nos 20 ans
au chagrin notre chez soi sans oublier
les copains du perron aujourd'hui
dispersés aux quatre roues on n'était
pas les prêtres ni curé ni malaise mais
papa nous aimait bien je te rappelle le
dimanche autour de la table ça riait
discuter
en nous c'est vrai et après
il invite à bouffer comme elle bouffe
tout le monde aujourd'hui au plus tard
et moi j'ai suivi puis tant qu'on révèle
quitter nos vieux meubles puis tant
qu'on va être sûr trouver tout fin seul
à oublier shopper moi j'ai fait de mon
mieux aujourd'hui tu bois tu 20 ça fait
plus sérieux
le père prend un coup de vieux
tout ça fait des vieux
je me fous du monde entier quand
frédéric me rappellent ils
allez salut frédéric
ceci fait là lui qui souffre au télémac
allez vous faites quoi la vidange
on va être grillé il arrive et on plante
des qui écoule belle qui daigneront nom
du black que ça très vite non alors
c'est qui qui au ritz michael jackson à
un petit black et alors qu'est ce que
vous avez gagné la deûle attendant c'est
bon michael jackson fait vingt-deux pays
avec ça et tu sais que tu vas vraiment
finir par en oublier le vote car les
tiens
[Musique]
aulas
[Applaudissements]
à
bien
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
oh
soir
ça va du boulevard delà le belge il est
où
salut ça va bonsoir ça va vous manger ça
vous ont jamais encore bien plein
américain tu vas bien tiré
soit tu fais quoi la communication
comme à chaque pression j'ai mon épouse
de coralie au téléphone
alors comment tu vas pjanic 1-1
ouais ouais ça va très bien le cheikh
fall world là je ne connais pas mon
genre vambre poelvoorde dents longues
le petit grégory c'est arrivé près de
chez moi
enfin vous prenez à il ya un mec qui
s'appelle ttbm il paraît que c'est à
dire très bien monté sa magasin car à
côté
à tout à l'heure tiens on va demander du
ketchup savait difficile de franchir la
barrière
ben oui je comprends la caméra sur ses
yeux on va voir du ketchup vous nous en
apporter dépit du champagne
vous avez du champagne californien du
champagne california
on va avoir du ketchup et du champagne
californien un chouette
non non je te demandais j'ai été la
révélation à la rentrée quand même
ah oui ouais comme ça qu'on appelle
beaucoup de monde un peu d'argent avant
de avant de faire
c'est arrivé près de chez vous qui
faisait du café théâtre
non jamais non non non avant de concéder
près de chez vous c'est qui oui c'est
moi oui ou non ces matins je vous écoute
dit moi une bonne oreille c'est
quelqu'un qui aimait bien les news est
allé bas vous étiez pas nombreux pour me
dire quand même allé le lire avant tout
à 10 mois alors qu'est ce que tu faisais
avant de faire c'est arrivé près de chez
vous c'est que ça nous a carrément opéré
au plafond s'étaient ingérées du dessin
pendant ce temps les fier de te
rencontrer très heureux parce que
vraiment sincèrement j'ai pas fait
fortune dans la flagornerie
mais je trouve ça très bien sur une
cassette et qu'on regarde il merci
beaucoup voilà ça me fait très plaisir
et bien alors je faisais avant choisir
du dessin pour enfants et de la photo
j'ai surtout une école de communication
eh bien je n'ai jamais si j'ai payé une
exposition pour les enfants pendant la
dépression pour apprendre les dangers la
pollution et puis qu'on fait c'est comme
apparemment ça servira qu est ce que tu
bouffes solutions alimentaires
[Rires]
et puis quand c'était terminé ces
nounous fumée sortir soit - ouais on est
le fils m'aide à marcher ou pas marché
il a bien fait lorsqu on ne s'attendait
pas du tout à ce succès la voiture je
peux plus payer tu peux me tutoyer la
boisson comme tu es belle si tu veux pas
non plus pourquoi les belges te dois de
le belge études pas beaucoup le canadien
le belge tout ça faisait quand même à
l'auberge tétouan et en france on est
très content d'avoir les belges et les
canadiens parce qu'on sait plus quoi
faire
heureusement il ya des communes belges
et chanteur canadien saeed secoue la
tête
c'est vraiment bien quand j'ai demandé
du champagne californien montanier qui
serait californie alors qu'est-ce qui
fait sur scène je suis pas je te mange
toutes les pommes de terre non non non
pas bon je joue un homme qui attend
vainement sa femme dans un café ouais et
qui souffre entre autres de ne pas être
reconnu dans son métier et nous savons
tous ce que c'est mais en plus ils
offrent davantage de sa part que sa
femme elle est reconnue dans ce qu'elle
fait alors que pour lui elle fait
quelque chose de tout à fait idiot ça
veut dire qu'elle fait enregistrer une
chanson idiote je me dis ça c'est sain
c'est mélissa et il souffre a laissé
tout cas ce projet fera dimanche mais
pourquoi
mais bon
[Musique]
j'ai pas mélissa tout à fait coralie
s'est pas inspiré de coralie cette
histoire non non coraline connaît pas un
succès que tu ne connaîtraient pas au
bien mieux bien mieux
on n'a pas besoin de chanter ce qui est
marrant qu'à paris on met autant de mal
à trouver du champagne une cigarette
merci c'était vraiment un moment atteint
encore aliments gelé qu'est-ce que tu en
fais pression mais je connais un petit
peu je crois que je te coupe l'appétit
maintenant on regarde ses relations avec
ses je crois que c'est de ma faute
on ne mange pas le badge et franchement
ce sont la belgique c'est vachement plus
américanisé que la france la belgique et
plus américanisé que la france non non
un truc comme ça on n'a pas nous en
belgique non non non non pas les
tournées non la belgique c'est bien
belle choix ouais c'est resté très
français la belgique annonce alors un
nom ça je suis d'accord mais c'est bien
mais alors attention les mecs à la honte
sur la conscience le rallye je veux
absolument que tu boivent du champagne à
formia attention attention beaucoup
bon alors attention vous êtes prêts
attention tout le monde est prêt 1 2 3
et bien c'est très con on sera foutu non
c'est bon un chinois voudraient du
champagne californien
g.skill à différents du champagne
français il est moins cher il est cher
parce que tout le monde ici en
californie il est moins cher c'est vrai
comme le coca c'est vrai qu'on dirait du
sprite sanaa couleurs du ca la couleur
du canada dry là le goût du canal rai
mais ce n'est pas du canada dry à l'apa
le prix de canada dry
c'est du champagne californien
[Musique]
on
il
[Musique]
oui
qui
[Musique]
bonjour vd champagne à bonne idée va il
effraie la corde au québec comme un
secteur de pau demain soir mais ça va se
voir enlever mois le free cpo merci d'en
mettre en page d'accueil
merci en bas
[Musique]
bonsoir c'est un staff des musées de
chantage
djama donne à la nouvelle chaufferie
voilà chez des amis comme ça tous les
soirs souvent servi j'ai même à mi démon
paul sa philosophie
oui tout à fait tunisair
alors c'est longtemps qu'il est comme ça
un petit moment gelé baptisé vous avez
tiré que j'ai créés a dit dans mon livre
il est baptisé exit pour françoise alors
david ginola on l'a un peu couvert pour
la caméra mais d'habitude son sexe sort
dès qu'ils voient des femmes que l'on
peut pas toucher en fait donné et on lui
a vraiment envie son sexe en cage de
façon à ce que son sexe ne sortait pas
il reste combien de temps comme ça
désert si toi qui décide de libérer ou
il te demande sinon c'est moi qui décide
j'ai pas l'habitude de les faire briller
quand même j'ai pitié où nous avons une
bonne mais presque
aulas alors là c'est un autre exemple
d'un jeune homme qui aime bien vivre 100
féminin dans paris dans dans la ville
s'appelle jean-louis le quotidien ici
s'appelle madonna
l'employé de banque dans la vie j'espère
quelque chose comme ça
ça s'arrête là il se contente de venir
chez toi pour s'habiller
oui il est très masculin dans la vie
même si aujourd'hui il a revêtu son
habit de rêve une bonne star s'est
préparé pour ces berlines sont ce soir
quand on n'est pas là qu'est ce qu'elle
fait comment maintenant puisque le fait
quand on éteint elle apprend à faire la
[ __ ] importing sont derrière elle
apprend à être l'oeil aux jeux l'adresse
comme ça parce que c'est son rêve
non tout comme une bouteille qui
sommeille vsab et thierry non
malheureusement oui tu es beau tu es
bien live via vivre son état [ __ ]
notre amie karine qui est dominatrice
débutante longtemps pour un province
dominateur jeu quand j'ai pas pris
médaille est là elle a de bonnes idées
je crois qu'elle gagnera bonne idée
c'est marine oui ça fait que l'intello
du sm caen il paraît que je suis là
pensent aux usa ouais c'est pas une
façon sinon j'aime pas parce que je suis
pas une intellectuelle qu'il y réfléchit
c'est pas une façon de trouver un alibi
culturel un peu non dits culturels
non c'est un peu ça je crois que quand
on écrit on a déjà les cris ouais mais
peut pas expliquer pourquoi c'est vrai
que une transe sm il ya une montée et
une descente commun et d'acide et c'est
ça que j'ai voulu comprendre mais en
tournée dans la transe ou les comores et
comme un canton 3 un acide penser que
c'est très proche de la transe des brom
puisque c'est les endorphines qui
fonctionne et je pense qu'il faut le
faire avec des gens sérieux parce que
pour moi le la dominatrice oui
dominateur c'est un acre accompagnateurs
dans la transe
bon on s'amuse à dire n'importe quoi sur
sado maso et je trouve que vous médias
vous avez le devoir de mettre les gens
en garde même sinon placement peut pas
faire n'importe quoi il faut pas le
tortionnaire fopac tortionnaires faut
jouer on n'est pas les sadiques un de
ces mots sado-maso ce une erreur on
n'est pas des sadiques
on est des masochistes dominant dominé
je crois qu'il faut apprendre à le dire
parce que ça on fait n'importe quoi mais
avant masoch il y avait des gens qu'il
pratique et lui la balle aurait pu
appeler ça le flou périssent mais moi j
adore flaubert des des choses très mal
dont on aurait pu appeler ça j'ai pas
socrates
ce sont des traces dans l'antiquité un
joli collier est-ce qu'on a des traces
de dans l'antiquité ou avant que que
maze auxquelles on croit que le frère
d'hérode se faisait enchaîné amant ouais
donc c'est une perversion fouet tout à
fait c'est pas un truc de fin de siècle
ils sont à la perversion de la fin du
20e siècle parce que le ciel pense qu'on
va chercher une autre vie de temps en
temps parce qu'on a besoin de se
débarrasser de son salut cher mais on va
chercher une autre vie ailleurs quelle
qu'elle soit que ce soit dans la musique
dans le virtuose les virtuoses aussi
presque la mort quand ils partent on a
besoin d'aller chercher autre chose
aussi certainement le sport n'importe
quoi mais c'est pour ça qu'il ya
beaucoup plage de pouvoir qui ont des
pratiques sadomasochistes oui mais moi
j'aime bien dire aussi qu'il ya des gens
très simples qui ont des pratiques
sadomasochistes je veux pas dire que je
vais entraîner les gens ne le dirai
jamais une chose pareille mais il ya des
gens très simples qui ont des pratiques
des fois très compliquée et qui viennent
quand on justement quand on cherche à
savoir pourquoi on s'aperçoit que c'est
quelque chose très intellectuel et ce ne
sont pas des intellectuels
alors ici au ici il ya des galères c'est
quoi les terrains eh bien il ya un
galérien qui vit son épreuve de force à
un don il est offert devient bien
souvent servir il vient quelques crpc
le capitaine corsaire sa maîtresse sont
chanceuses fait le tour pour voir d'où
on vient
il reste longtemps
il reste combien de temps quand il vient
par exemple celui là pas trop mais j'en
ai un qui reste parce que 24 heures
je jette des autres je me donne à manger
il reste dans sa tranche 1 en plus
enfantin du coup c'est d'être en prison
non c'est je crois qu'il fonda celui-là
est fantasmé sur les filles
pirates ouais mais il a identifié le
capitaine à sa maîtresse et l'huile et
le galérien tant de temps ensemble à
calmer les coups de fouet puis voilà on
leur met dedans
voilà si je veux venir l'heure pour être
initiés ou sm parce que quand tu veux
ouais je sais cher on parle jamais
d'argent
moi je gagne ma vie autrement et moi
j'adore les accessoires j'aime bien
comme on mène on voyage dans les soirées
sm j'aime bien qu'on installe donjon le
reste c'est à moins d'importance si je
viens pour la première fois tu vas me
faire toi même tu vas me tester comment
monsieur je vais un peu je vais faire je
vais lui ai travaillé comme nîmes si
canal à wyeth à tête comme une
psychanalyse
je vais essayer de fouiller dans son
enfance pour moi parce qu'en fait la
dominatrice ou dominateur doit imposer
ce que tu désires mais à aucun moment
qu'ils ne pouvaient présenter ton
programme
elle doit agir avec des clés est visible
c'est ça qui est plus dur c'est toi qui
va décider de du programme en fonction
d'une conversation que j'aurai avec toi
je dis ça peut se traduire commandant
les premières séances par exemple et des
premières choses que je crois qu'il est
important dans les premières séances
d'abord de savoir à qui on a affaire
ce que la personne cherche et surtout
ses rêves d'enfance parce que tout est
là dedans
par exemple les gens qui aiment se faire
attacher sont des gens qui ont éprouvé
une volupté en jour nous en bien et en
étant attaché allez vous comme ont
atteint cela
je pense que tu mens tu es quand tu veux
ce maillot bon voilà alors si tu me dis
ça bien sûr je vais penser non mais
j'aimais bien le faire de chez auto
thème par exemple tu vois quand on était
petit est-ce que c'était des aliens il
revient chez les indiens maintenant j'ai
envie de te faire attacher des nues ou à
gauche maintenant c'est par chris moore
avait été dire ouais ce moment j'ai des
ga crise de bande edge avec ma table
d'ailleurs sur la table toute attache
avec des ceintures mur je te sèvres
j'ouvre la cie stach stach ap ap l'avant
j'ouvre là pour mettre des cours et ton
sexe la paume et essence
il ya des gens qui vont sous la cape il
ya des gens qui veulent aider les gens
qui dormait pendant quelqu'un et
d'attachés sur le ventre la sarre et il
a des gens qui soutenaient que sordo sa
magazine allemand qui est devenu le
marquis entre temps c'est pas quelqu'un
qui auront envie que je l'écrasé main
figurait dessus la personne elles font
briller madonna sans y passer comme
personne le faire le cendrier humain
merci on peut dire avoir regardé rien
oui bien sûr
la bomba adios 1 adios courage
on va françois ça dure salut et merci
d'être venu au revoir romano n'a pas
fini on va chez ramier bonne étude va
bientôt voir monsieur maintenant tu peux
que lui libérer je veux finir on met ces
impies gedo une station de métro
entouré de biche cours égal
grand magasin atelier de matin le
restaurant pour humains égal
lance le chanteur décor
[Musique]
voilà merci à ma demande de porter à 700
chaînes publiques
voilà voilà
selon ces rumeurs
bienvenue à risque égal débit diamond
games à l'arrivée ça va vous pouvez
entrer
[Musique]
voilà samedi a été très chaud de toutes
les créatures et débile
nous avons toujours des créatures
superbe ici avant tout va bien effet
accès et actuel qui s'occupe de toute la
direction artistique
bonjour voila je ne sais quoi d croirait
soir chris ivery bbc les soirées pour
tous les clubbers de paris donc les gens
vraiment y aime la fête pour la fête
ceux qui veulent sortir pour prendre la
tête ça pue
du pente en quoi donc au festival est
apparent et alison kong à tous les
français qui y est c'est vraiment à dire
surtout ce look et les mélanges ça qu'on
aime
[Musique]
souviens-toi la première première fois
la première fois de quoi je me suis bien
en forme
oui mais c'était un garçon d'amputer
fragasso aulas il faut avoir du souvenir
j'avais 14 ans à bâle la saison je me
mets ton femmes
ah ouais ouais mais bon jusqu'à une
période à ce qu'on s'amusait bien mais
maintenant on est obligé de se maquiller
pour faire la fête devrait déjà être un
peu triste quand même quelque part c'est
vachement bien acquis et là oui là je
pourrai y a plus non non non c'est pas
ça c'est très beau je suis sûr c'est
très beau à l'image c'est vrai ouais
c'est comment ton nom de scène c'est
dallas et baby time nuit ça tiens ça
tient un peu de moi tu mets pas la route
sais tu dit thierry guillemot et béton
non dans la vie c'est comment chris noth
moi je suis meilleur
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le leader des tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu